ce dossier ukrainien
il est aussi au coeur d'une rencontre en
ce moment à berlin entre le président
français emmanuel macron et le nouveau
chancelier allemand olaf scholz tous
deux devraient tenter d'adopter une
position commune face à moscou à
bruxelles où cette rencontre est suivi
de très près par leurs partenaires
européens on retrouve alix le bourdon
notre correspondante
une rencontre qui va être suivie de très
près en effet surtout au lendemain du
conseil affaires étrangères qui a eu
lieu ici à bruxelles réunion à l'issue
de laquelle on a pu lire des communiqués
dans lesquels étaient souligné l'unité
entre américains et européens dans ce
dossier ukrainien mais dans le même
temps on a bien vu que les approches
divergent notamment sur l'imminence de
la menace russe d'ailleurs le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell a
bien rappelé hier que pour le moment les
européens n'allait pas faire comme les
américains en évacuant leur ambassade et
puis on sait aussi que les approches
divergent au sein même de l'union
européenne et c'est berlin d'abord qui
sème le doute sur cette unité que les
européens cherchent à afficher il ya
d'abord eu les propos controversés sur
la russie du chef de la marine allemande
qui a dû démissionner ce week-end il ya
aussi ce refus persistant de berlin de
livrer des armes à l'ukraine alors que
les états unis le royaume uni ou les
pays baltes ont annoncé l'envoi
d'équipement et puis il ya aussi ce
manque de lisibilité au sein de la
coalition en allemagne sur l'attitude à
adopter face à l'eire à face à la russie
avec cette question centrale faut-il
inclure le gazoduc north stream 2 qui
relie la russie à l'allemagne dans les
sanctions qui seraient adoptés en cas
d'invasion de l'ukraine et puis il ya
aussi la france vous le savez qui prône
une proposition européenne c'est ce que
ce qui est manuel macron à développer
dans son discours face au parlement
européen la semaine dernière un ordre de
sécurité collectives auxquelles est bien
les pays de l'est de l'europe ne sont
pas prêts à adhérer un puisque pour le
moment et bien ils préfèrent déléguer
leur sécurité à l'otan et aux états unis